I'm genetic amaura Dean of the School of
Social Work and I'm delighted to welcome
you all here this afternoon I know that
she could have been somewhere else and
so it means even more to us that you're
here we are actually launching a very
very exciting center today and this is a
center for complicated grief for those
of you who are not familiar with the
phenomenon called complicated grief let
me tell you that there are people who
said to me what isn't grief all the same
I mean you know why is this
distinguished somehow and it is a
distinct form of grief it's really one
that is long-lasting all-encompassing it
absorbs the individual and it leaves the
person who's experiencing it feeling
really stuck it can go on for years and
years so we can only really have the
center because we are fortunate enough
to have on our faculty dr. Catherine
shear who we were able to recruit from
the University of Pittsburgh she is an
expert in the area in fact she's done
much of the groundbreaking research and
has also been able to formulate both the
assessment tools as well as the
interventions contributed to formulating
the interventions that are very
important for people who are
experiencing complicated grief now it's
unfortunate that I have to say this it's
fortunate that we have Catherine with us
but we are living in an era it seems
when we are even more aware of all of
the natural disasters that can affect us
mass shootings if you will the wonderful
aging of the population in huge numbers
it's really a demographic revolution but
with that comes also the specter of
losing people sometimes at the end of
their life terrorism and I could go on
and on we are impacted in our daily
lives in ways that we never before were
and so the center on complicated grief
becomes even more important and we are
delighted that
we have the expert to be heading the
center this afternoon we have a number
of experts who you'll hear from and they
will share their perspectives dr. George
wanna know who George could you stand
just for a minute he'll come up a little
later he is a professor at Teachers
College and an expert who has focused on
human resilience and I teach a course on
military Social Work and I mentioned
that dr. Bonanno has mentioned the
importance of remembering the resilience
of our warriors not just focusing on the
devastation that's there but also their
resilience he is a clinical psychologist
and we have with us as well dr. Zoe
Donaldson and so here there she is and
dr. Donaldson is a neuro geneticist her
focuses on risk and resilience as well
and we're pleased to have her she
actually has done some research on the
neurobiology of grief we have Stephanie
Moberg and Stephanie I saw you just a
minute ago as she stepped up there she
is Stephanie Moberg is actually going to
share with you her own personal
experience of having gone through
complicated grief of knowing what that's
like and what it's like to actually
receive assistance so that she could get
well beyond a phenomenon and finally we
will be hearing from two very important
people of course dr. Katherine shear the
Marian Kenworthy professor of psychiatry
and Social Work it's a very long title
who is heading the center we are going
to hear from her about the mission of
the center and its planned as well as as
its current activities and last but not
least we will be hearing from an Kaplan
who is one of the trustees of the
University and my hope is that an will
be able to note for you some of the
reasons why the center is so important
to the University as well so let me
start by welcoming dr. Bernardo to the
podium and he will spend a few minutes
to sharing with you some of his own
perspectives on
grief and resilience
you